must have heard me loving dying light is
like loving a petulant child it does
good things for a while and you cheer it
on because everything's going so well
and then it gets in trouble it does
something so ridiculous you can only cry
out why are you doing this then again if
you come to dying light because of
developer Techland pedigree this is part
of your expectation a fun game with a
lot of potential a smattering of
frustration and the occasional glitch
but as troubled as dying light off and
ends it's still special and so you stick
with it even when you want to tell it to
go stand in the corner until it's
willing to behave many of the
expectations arise from tech lands Dead
Island games and rightfully so this is a
zombie game with weapon crafting a
stamina meter lots of fetch quests and
plenty of head bludgeoning dying light
however sets itself apart rather quickly
particularly with its parkour system
which sees you running across its two
large urban areas from a first-person
view it takes a short while to get used
to climbing onto ledges which requires
you to be looking at them in the proper
way but then it's off to the races and
you're running across rooftops and
sneering at the zombies below most of
which can't handle a big climb rushing
through the open world this way is fun
and it energizes certain moments of
tension the Far Cry comparisons are
obvious such as with the way you unlock
a few of the game's safe houses by
climbing tall towers but the climbing
requires more finesse than it does in
Far Cry 4 and some of the towers are
outrageously tall making the whole thing
a tense
exercise in precision and tension is the
second aspect of dying light that sets
it apart from its zombie game peers
there are some light-hearted references
and cute visual gags for the most part
this is a dead serious post outbreak
world most important to the sense of
tension is the day/night cycle when
night falls particularly dangerous and
fast zombies roam the city and the
entire timber changes you need to be
wary of the vision cone
of those baddies and avoid direct
confrontation but you'll occasionally
get mobbed in spite of your careful
movement these undead are more
persistent than the Liberty City Police
Department so the best option is to run
run run until you lose them you can hold
a button to look behind you and see how
close they are and talk about tense
moments it's been a while since a zombie
game actually scared me but that look
behind you move reveals some startling
sights throw in a three pronged upgrade
system that makes you stronger and more
agile as the game progresses and you
have the foundation of a great game alas
dying light flounders too often for it
to achieve true greatness though it will
surely develop the same kind of cult
following that Dead Island has earned
the open-air exploration can be
downright terrific particularly in the
second half when you enter the old town
district and encounter the game's best
climbing and leaping paths but when
dying light puts you to work the results
are wildly inconsistent for many hours
of the super long game you're an errand
boy a problem so prevalent that lead
character Kyle crane even remarks upon
it look all I want to do is get this
over with go flip the switch go collect
crayons or mushrooms or coffee or bla
bla bla bla bla bla
the missions get more interesting just
in time to get more frustrating there's
a timed mission in which you plant bombs
while besieged by zombies there's an
ambush by Gunners while you swim in
which it's easy to be killed before you
can even understand what's going on you
get plenty of tools to help you survive
throwing stars tons of melee weapons and
so on but some of these missions are
just set up in such frustrating ways
that you want to shake your fist and
shout what were you thinking to
developer Techland but that's dying
light for you the highs are really high
like player invasions that turn the game
into a competitive arena for a bit you
can adventure cooperatively but it's
this sudden competition in which player
controlled monsters come after you and
try to kill you in freaky ways that adds
real spice to the mix but then the game
will do some weird or bad thing like
getting you stuck between a fence and
the ground or putting you in a tiny area
with a huge ground
pounding thug or obscuring the screen
with so much hazen bloom during a boss
fight that you can only shake your head
but i gotta say the parkour is tight the
world looks good and the story while
cliched got me to actually care about
these people and so i still root for
dying light even when it tries so hard
to dispel my love sorry dying light but
i'm sticking by your side
you